Let's talk now a little bit about implicit DAX.
These are the options that you have readily available when you right-click on a value,
just like we did with that 3.3 million that we saw in the demo.
It will initially always default to sum,
which is I think the most commonly used option.
But as you can see in this screenshot I have here,
there are a number of other options readily available.
Implicit DAX is essentially a series of
commonly used preset calculations that require no extra work for you.
They're already available in the Power BI reporting view.
When you're using implicit DAX,
you're going to have options that are very similar to
what you're used to an Excel, including sum,
average, min, just in
a reporting context with
the same general options that you're seeing on the right-hand side.
The caveat here is that
these implicit DAX options can only be used on an aggregatable column.
For example, you're not going to be able to use this on a text string.
The way that you can tell
whether or not the relevant column or in the reporting contexts the field
is an option for implicit DAX is to look for
the sum symbol sitting next to it on the reporting pin.
Let's play with implicit DAX a little bit,
like we talked about a little bit before on the slide.
When we are looking at the values and we pull them in from the fields on to the visuals,
you have some as your default,
but you have other options readily available.
We can leave this as some.
But we can also add the same value and use average.
We can add it again and make it the minimum,
and we can continue to add it as many times as we wanted.
We can of course add other values as well.
Any of these that had this little E symbol you're able to add.
They'll default to sum,
but you can make them whatever of these options you want very easily.
Of course, if the format like with average of
amount doesn't suit you or your purposes for reporting,
you can always adjust that.
The way that you adjust that is by selecting the source value and then going
up to the column tools
to adjust not the type but the format.
We can do this for the values by adding currency if it wasn't there already,
or by adjusting so that we have
just two decimal places rather than a seemingly infinite number.
One more thing that we should touch on now that we have
this wonderful selection of filters available,
is that we can go into the filter pane and make further adjustments here.
Something that we'll touch on as we move through filters in greater detail.